yes
please use your microphone to speak so
we can all hear you again welcome this
is a subcommittee work session on HP
1644fn
um and it's a relative to the placement
of telecommunication antenna and
establishing a registry for residents
who are experiencing biological
exemptions from Wireless radiation
exposure
I will say that we've had a couple of
meetings before and the President Bill
as it was introduced is not going to
happen but the purpose of this
subcommittee is to determine very simply
thank you uh the purpose of this
subcommittee meeting here is to
determine whether or not we will
recommend to the full committee if there
should be further legislative
legislative action to be done that does
that does not necessarily mean that it
would say that we recommend passage of
the current bill it does not necessarily
mean that we would be recommending a
specific Bill to be put into the current
system it merely says that we feel some
type of legislative action of some
general
subject
is recommended to be put forth at some
time in the future it would be up to the
full committee to decide how they want
to vote on that recommendation or the
subcommittee could recommend that we
don't feel there is a need for further
legislative action and we could proceed
with that recommended recommendation to
the full committee as well
with that being said I'd like to
introduce the subcommittee members that
are here present today is representative
Nader representative partial
representative Kelly Pitts
myself and representative white is on
the subcommittee but he's not present
here today
these are the members that would be
voting on our recommendation today
those are the only people that are
assigned to the subcommittee as as
voting members
um with that being said I've had a
request from representative abrami to
make a a few minute statement so
thank you Mr chair
of course I appreciate being a
non-voting member on this panel I
appreciate that and uh appreciate that
that you allowed us to do not zoom but
uh
what are we doing
teams teams uh to uh to bring in some
other additional voices that we didn't
hear from in the prior meetings that
we've had on this
and uh Mike obviously my goal is to keep
this alive not necessarily in the form
that it was to build I agreeing I
understand that bill is gone
uh the 1644 but to keep the whole
concept in the discussion of of not
necessary 5G
but RF radiation is what we're talking
about here so uh with that I I uh we
have three three new voices Theodore
Theodora scarato
who'll talk to us about what
municipalities are doing and it's the
first handout that you see the glossy
one that she'll be speaking from
and then uh and uh what what what's
going on in municipalities and what's
going on with other research Susan
Foster I don't know if she's on yet uh
who's who was involved with the
California firefighters years ago
uh and she'll explain what happened
there
and and Scott
um McAuliffe uh who's uh who's an
attorney who's been looking at these
issues for for many years
and then we'll wrap up with CeCe
Doucette uh who you've heard from before
uh uh but who's going to talk about our
education because I think the the chair
asked me last week what kind of
legislation would you be thinking about
and one and representative Kelly Pitts
had already suggested maybe legislation
related to RF education
which we certainly will probably try to
file a bill there
but the other was is how do we Empower
our municipalities to have some
additional say in the whole issue of
placement of towers in their communities
so they're trying to make it more of a
local thing and so those are those are
the two areas that we're thinking now of
legislation for next year
that would come under the heading of
basically RF radiation so uh with that I
want to thank you Mr chair and we'll go
from there
uh thank you representative abrami I
would like to add that in addition
um representative lewicki is here and
he's going to offer a few words uh on
his ideas involving frequency that he
feels uh hasn't been spoken about enough
and at some point in time we'll
introduce him to to have a say on that
if there's anybody else here who came
here to prepare something of a brief
statement I would need to have their
names brought up here so I can call on
them if not we would just proceed with a
discussion and uh my aim is to God is to
be out of here before 12 noon or sooner
so uh we have your
picture
okay
thank you I will try to alter if I can I
understand we are on a telecast here
called teams
it's hard for me to be in this room
um
okay and you plan to speak to it I hope
too okay all right yeah a little
sensitive instruments okay
uh with that said um
okay
okay so so we'll start with the first
person that is uh broadcasting from afar
which was is um
theodorus scarato
uh you're on
honored and I'd be glad to answer
questions at the end I did send a packet
with um information can you hear me
oh yes
okay okay great thanks so I'm executive
director of Environmental Health Trust
and we're a scientific
tank focused on publishing research
raising Awareness on science-based
measures to prevent cancer and other
disease focusing on environmental health
issues I know that you're familiar by
now with our lawsuit against the FCC
where we challenged their decision not
to update the fcc's 1996 limits for
exposure to regular frequency radiation
so in 2021 when the FCC was deemed by
the U.S court of appeals to the D.C
circuit as having been arbitrary and
capricious in its refusal to update the
U.S FCC limits which were set in 1996
the court found that the FCC had ignored
record evidence including the impacts of
long-term Wireless exposure because
there has been no report by any federal
agency reviewing the impact of long-term
exposure especially to children and in
the new 5G environment the testimony of
people injured by Wireless radiation
impacts to the environment and
non-cancer impacts impacts the
developing brain and reproduction now
the FCC was mandated to establish
reasonable record of review of the
evidence and to address issues that it
had ignored like children long-term
exposure and so forth but so far the FCC
has not responded so in my packet and I
can send you a online one that has links
to everything that is listed in there we
address how the FCC
limits and the case of cell tower
radiation really exemplifies the concept
of a regulatory Gap
there was no pre-market safety testing
for long-term damages from non-ionizing
radiation exposure by any federal agency
certainly not on up-to-date science
there was no there is no post-market
surveillance for health effects
there's been a risk analysis for
long-term effects yet there's an Ever
accumulating body of independent science
showing harmful effects uh is biological
effects adverse biological levels that
are in FCC limits
I also have in the packet page on
various setbacks of different
municipalities around the country uh
that you have in front of you like
Shelburne Massachusetts 3 000 people
schools and 1 500 homes Copake New York
1500 feet home schools churches and
public buildings and so forth but what I
really wanted to address
was some of the information that's been
presented
that makes it seem like our federal
agencies have in fact opined or had an
opinion about whether radio frequency
radiation is safe or not
first of all the FDA
has no Authority regards to sell to poor
radiation
and has not reviewed the totality of at
least in any public way that we are
aware
and just uh I have a quote in the packet
where a mother wrote to the FDA and
actually several responses from the FDA
at this point and she requested safety
data on the small cell that was right in
front of her
and the director of the FDA office of
policy Center for devices and
radiological Health responded the FDA
does not regulate cell towers or cell
tower radiation therefore the FDA has no
studies or information on cell tower to
um there's a Pittsburgh law review
article entitled why radioency radiation
standards have failed to keep up with
technology that concludes the FCC and
FDA have failed their obligation to
prescribe safe radio frequency radiation
guidelines produced from wireless
communication devices to protect the
public health and safety
so what about the CDC
well there are no scientific reviews by
the CDC on wireless radiation that
evaluated the science in any systematic
way or in any way actually that we're
aware of in fact our investigations
found that the CDC hired a consultant
with long-standing wireless industry
ties to serve subject matter expert on
their pages on non-ionizing radiation
and Wireless wearables
and we have all of that on our website
and they also I'll link to that
the National Cancer Institute
there are no scientific research reports
by the National Cancer Institute that
exist regarding 5G cell tower or even
cell phone safety and
um I myself
contacted the National Cancer Institute
in 2016 because I had been told by my
municipality that the NCI somehow
supported the limits or had reviewed
this issue
and they responded back to me a
literature review
neither the literature reviews for the
fact sheet safe to determinate
and of course uh the New Hampshire uh
5G commit commission commissioner Denise
ricciardi uh got a response back from
the National Cancer Institute most
recently and I'll quote the NCI is not
involved in the regulation of radio
frequency Communications infrastructure
of devices where do we make
recommendations policies related to this
technology
now the American Cancer Society also has
cited as somehow supporting FCC limits
or saying that all you know providing
services
but this is not true
the American Cancer States very clearly
that they don't have an official
position or statement on whether or not
radio frequency radiation from cell
towers or others is a cause of cancer
and that's on their website and they
have not done any kind of review uh
related to wireless radio frequency
radiation
the back story that after World War II
the U.S had developed a rather robust
research program involving several U.S
agencies
in 1984
the Environmental Protection Agency
released a report on the biological
effects of electromagnetic fields and uh
actually in the early 90s the EPA was
the recommended agency to develop human
exposure limits
however at the mid 90s was also when
there was Heavy lobbying for the Telecom
in fact it was the most heavily lobbied
bill at that time ever
and by the time it passed in 1996 the
Environmental Protection Agency had been
fully defunded from their work on
electromagnetic fields and uh that was a
few months after actually they had
presented the SEC how they were
developing safety limits that would be
based on heating effect
as well as non-thermal non-heating uh
biological effects but they were fully
defunded from developing safety limits
in fact we don't have federally
developed safety limits those are
adopted limits by the FCC
so in 2020 I wrote the Environmental
Protection Agency about their opinion
and they responded epa's last review was
in the 1984 document to refer to the
biological effects of radio radiation
and they also said that the EPA does not
currently have a funded mandate for
radio frequency radiation manners and
what about the World Health Organization
that's also been quoted as somehow
providing safety influences
there is a web page that says no adverse
short prolonged helps have been shown
however
that is not based on a review of the
totality of the science and in fact
there are two separate entities
underneath the World Health Organization
umbrella one is the World Health
Organization EMF project that drafted
these online websites that everyone read
that we think provides safety assurances
and there are numerous published papers
documenting a long-standing industry
ties to the writers of these very web
and then there's an entity the
international Agency for research on
cancer which classified radio frequency
radiation as a possible carcinogen back
into 11. these are two separate entities
now the international Agency for
research on cancer has not convened
their expert working group to make
another determination based on the
newest science the animal studies and
other human studies that have been
published
um so the who EMF project web pages are
not official determinations and actually
to just dive slightly even deeper if you
actually look at the who EMS side you'll
see that they haven't made any uh done
any reports since 1993. you can go to uh
the list where they have their
monographs and their reports and 1993 is
the last report on radio frequency
radiation
there's a 2022 letter that was published
in the Journal of the American Medical
Association by safe Jed Allen I'm
bringing this up because I have heard
statements uh to the committee that the
majority of studies don't find effects
but what this publication with this
letter fights that in fact the majority
of the latest science social effects
I'll just quote the 261 studies looking
at oxidative effects from radio
frequency radiation exposure
240 or 91 show damage of the 346 studies
on effects of radio frequency radiation
on genes
224 65 reported genetic damage
of the 300 36 study published on radio
frequency neurological effects 73
reported effects and only 27 percent
should go up at and there's a
Switzerland Institute of the environment
expert review which was published that
found
increased oxidative stress in the
majority of animal cell studies with
exposures within regulatory limits
so what federal agency
has authority of both funding or
studying cell tower radiation making
sure that the people and environment are
protected
and the answer is none there actually is
no federal agency with any health or uh
or environment expertise that is
ensuring safety that's looking at the
research
um
scientifically looking at the level but
which effects have been found in studies
evaluating the uh the studies for their
quality and making a determination
other countries not the United States
they monitor the radio frequency levels
some have real-time 5G monitoring
stations some have uh monitors which are
in your schools or other vulnerable
areas as they combined and they
are writing in a public way there's web
where you can look up what is the level
what are the level here what a level
there in France if you want to know what
the level is in your community you go to
your mayor your request a reading and
you can get that by law in a lot of
countries have it free posted on
websites so when it comes to the ambient
radiation from cell towers
we have a regulatory Gap
and
I am glad and questions I guess I would
like to end with this one quote from a
letter that was published in the Journal
of the National Cancer Institute and the
experts who published this let it's
about a study that seemed to show uh
safety but actually the design of it
it was irrelevant to the way we use
technology today and the way we're
the former Director of National
Institutes of Environmental Health
Sciences Dr Linda Birnbaum Hugh Taylor
who's the chief obstetric City Hospital
and Dr Deborah Davis and
um Professor Paul beneshai and a
neurosurgeon Hillel Baldwin published
this letter which states the majority of
animal and cell Studies have found
non-hypnizing radio frequency radiation
can induce oxidative stress a key
characteristic of human carcinogen in a
way that radio frequency can initiate or
promote tumor development as well as
play a role in the development of other
diseases
DNA damage and cancer and
state-of-the-art studies signal the need
for the public to reduce exposures to
radio frequency radiation now
and I'm glad to answer any questions as
well
thank you so much thank you mrado uh
before I I go on to that I did receive a
note here so I will make an announcement
uh uh apparently some observers have
come in here with signs
signs or placards are not allowed in the
committee room if you would be so kind
as to place them outside in the hallway
please so that they're not in this
community room I I know they're not
being shown here that's fine but I would
prefer that the signs be kept outside of
this committee room if you can make that
with that being said uh does the
committee have any questions yes uh
you only have to put up with me for a
of course green would be off how
we're back in session
um
my question is why
or do you think that it would be
beneficial for the Health and Human
Services
to join with the Science and Technology
and the municipal County Government
to
explore getting information out about
this subject I I think it's not a one a
one Committee in my mind it's not a one
committee effort and I do believe that
5G is
being deployed as we speak
and we don't know where
the other
situation that we have uh as a committee
is that we have given
I don't want to say given up but we have
uh given up the ability to regulate
communication so it has to be done in my
mind on a local level what do you think
about those entities joining together
yeah well we have recommended that
oh sorry I'm getting feedback so it I
have to just not hear the feedback when
I speak of my apologies
um so we are recommending that agencies
with health expertise
be involved in a full review of the
totality of the science I mean right now
the feds you know there's no one
watching the ball that's what we have a
situation where everyone's pointing at
everyone else but there isn't an entity
doing that so at the federal level
unless it you know it has not been made
public where there's been any overview
of this issue so it would make sense for
the health you know expert agencies with
health expertise to be looking at this
issue it really need there needs to be a
full and Frank
transparent
review of all of the science with the
ability for comments just like you would
thank you at may I of course the and and
what about the follow-up since we as a
federal government perhaps is lagging a
little bit
um the state government really doesn't
have the authority
unless we declare this an emergency
working with the local level because
that's where you can
I believe control we were talking about
where these things go up these towers
and the proximity to schools and
hospitals so also working with local
because it seems to me that that's the
way it has to proceed here have you any
other experience with that
well at the local level it is my
understanding that what other
communities are doing is having
preferences that there can be priority
locations rather than every space is
available to companies but prioritizing
career facilities should be because you
can't prohibit service however a
communities can at the local level uh
you know make decisions about
where placements should be based on the
local state and federal law so
um and and I am not a lawyer who works
in uh the issue of New Hampshire law so
I can't speak any further than that but
I can't say that around the country
communities are uh having more
responsible placement and I think one
thing is that a lot of decision makers
you know at the very local level they
don't know that they don't know what
other communities are doing they don't
know they're they're being told that
they can't do anything that the in fact
I'm going to quote a decision maker in
my community who said and I quote they
were commanded by the FCC and quote to
allow cell towers in homes in a
residential area and that's really not
true it's it's really uh not factual so
I think sussing out what is what
communities can do and empowering
communities to do the most that they can
to just protect their residential
Communities In Schools and vulnerable
areas is something that many experts are
advocating
thank you
any more questions from our subcommittee
representative partial
yes thank you for your presentation and
for taking my question
I am looking at the paper that you uh
submitted to us oh and I'm wondering if
you need a copy of your testimony as
well
is that possible yeah thank you so much
um and I'm seeing a number of small
towns small municipalities actually
taking
uh action against the FCC do you think
that's
uh well how can I say this uh
is that the most appropriate place to uh
seek uh action to
um investigate the situation
because do the local communities
actually have the resources is my real
I think I'm hearing you correctly it's a
little fuzzy
um but you're wondering about local
action as an appropriate Avenue
um and so what are you referring to
specifically because I think what's
happened is local communities are trying
to have authority in their community and
so they are filing are you talking about
um New York or well I'm wondering really
how these communities that you listed
here actually made this change in their
local ordinances to make these things
possible
um considering that uh it's a
municipality
um
basically questioning the FCC rather
than their uh State you know it's it
almost seems like the mouse against the
elephant situation is it the most
effective way to question FCC
um
uh legislation by having local
communities do this or it would be
better on a state level
well that's a really good question and I
think some of the further uh testifiers
are going to address this more deeply
but I will tell you that in our
community in Montgomery County Maryland
where I live the county actually filed a
lawsuit against the filed against the
FCC saying they were putting the cart
before the horse that they had that they
were streamlining in the 2019 and 18 uh
rules and regulations that facts tracked
5G and small cells into communities
without having fully reviewed the 1996
limits now what ended up happening was
the FCC made a decision that in
um that which is what we which was what
environmental health trust and their
petitioners filed against saying that we
don't have to update our limits so then
the case that the county these are two
separate cases the case that the county
put forward ended up being moot however
that wasn't based on the merits of the
case it was simply that the FCC had just
made made its decision but it really
remains a really good question I mean
how can we Fast Track these local
communities are being told uh by uh in
various
um you know uh information that's being
put forward to them that they have to
allow cell antennas near homes and by
the way in Washington DC where the
people were not given a voice and there
was no transparent process the setback
is 10 feet
now how can this be when we have these
limits that haven't been fully reviewed
and that's really the question it comes
down to the local communities where
people are getting these installations
in front of their homes and they're
asking the very simple question is this
safe
and how do you know it's safe and how do
I know you know this is something that
for for every other issue we would have
a data and documents and a full and
transparent review we would know what
we're even exposed to whereas in the
United States we don't have uh Federal
oversight as we do with many other
issues and certainly not like they're
like that so much I know we have a
lawyer also uh who can answer some of
the more the questions about
municipalities as well yeah yes thank
you so much uh for your presentation uh
is comment for the chair a brief yes uh
I think could we switch up and have uh
Scott Scott
um call off go first because I think
it'll he'll answer these questions okay
yes I was just going to say thank you
very much for your testimony I have
given a lot of leeway this morning to
the first presenter I will thank you
very much for that uh but we knew if we
can keep our next presentations a little
bit shorter that would be great to allow
us time for for more questions so with
that being said I will invite Mr Scott
McCullough to go on next to brief and
then after that we'll I'll turn my
attention to a testifier from from the
other side so we can keep this balanced
go ahead Mr McCulloch
thank you very much I hope you can hear
me
fine
thank you my name is Chicago Cub I'm a
telecommunications lawyer
um been practicing in this area for
almost 40 years now
over the last couple of years there's
I've been in the wireless space more
particularly dealing with national
standards and also working within
municipalities and counties helping them
develop ordinances so that they can
maintain the flexibility that Congress
gave them while still adhering to the
few restrictions that Congress didn't
put in place
well I I'd like to start out very
quickly talking about a couple of other
recommendations in the commission Rec uh
report specifically recommendations 2 8
and 12.
I think these are really important
nothing in the communications Act
reports or the FCC rules
purports to restrict
what a state or a local jurisdiction
itself can say
or do by way of Education
to the citizens
they can conduct studies if they wish
they can
um
make some required disclosures of the
wireless industry although some carriers
required in that area
um they can to some extent
um
disclose what the science is not to some
extent but fully disclose what the
science is in this area they can help
citizens that are concerned about
exposure find ways to reduce that
exposure acting in on their own
now let's get to the issue that I think
is probably of
most interest to me on this committee
and that is what can local jurisdictions
do
the wireless industry of course tells
all these cities that their hands are
completely tied that is not true what
they have is about three strings around
what they cannot do is they cannot
discriminate between types of
telecommunication Services unreasonably
discriminate
they cannot affectively prohibit
the provision of service
and they cannot regulate
Emissions on the basis of the
environmental effects of those but that
still leaves lots of flexibility within
local jurisdictions
they are still free
to exercise regulation that is
consistent with their local values with
a concern to property values and they
can
make sure that the facilities are there
are put into place that is safe
and does not ruin visual views
um you know they can they can make sure
that the facilities have proper
Aesthetics which is the term that is
used
so just to give you a couple of examples
um
a local jurisdiction
can on safe grounds
impose what are called Folsom if you
have a 100 foot Tower
you can require that that Tower be
placed so that if it were to fall
the fall zone or the or the area where
it will work and fall without hurting
anything
can be you know 100 percent or 125
because typically when these things fall
they created to brief you so a
municipality could say if you've got a
100 foot Tower you can't have
residential or business buildings or
streets within
125 feet
equally important they can have what are
called setbacks they can impose
presumptive setbacks so that
for example a wireless facility cannot
be within 500 or 700 feet or uh like the
commission recommended
even up to 15 or 1600 feet
notice I said presumptive
when it comes to setbacks however
you do need to have what we call a
waiver process in place
so that even though the general rule
would prohibit placing of a facility in
a given location say they wanted 300
feet from a residential area and the
setback is 750 feet or 1500 feet if
there was a waiver process in place so
that the wireless carrier can come in
and show
that unless it gets a permit in this
specific location
then it would suffer an effective
prohibition of service
the local jurisdiction can impose the
level of the burden of proof that is
required to rebut the presumption
many jurisdictions require clear and
convincing evidence
in other words
it typically it let's just say you want
to have a 750 or 1600 foot setback from
residential areas
that would basically rule out a small
cell or a macro in a residential area
but if the wireless carrier you can come
in and say you know I've got to have it
right here in this spot in the middle of
this residential area
or else I will suffer and hopeful
prohibition
the local jurisdiction can then make we
will give you that waiver if you prove
effective prohibition through clear and
convincing evidence that will pass most
under the federal law
let me give you a couple of examples
Bedford New Hampshire
has a 100 percent fall zone requirement
and a 750 setback requirement for
residential
Scarsdale New York
has 500 foot setbacks from residential
daycare facilities schools houses of
worship and Parklands Scarsdale also
requires that facilities be 1 000 feet
apart from each other so if there is a
small cell in one location somebody else
cannot put a small cell within month
thousand feet of that one
a Shelbourne of Massachusetts has a 1500
foot setback requirement for residential
structure
like 3 000 put spent back from the
property lines of schools
kopaki New York and I may be
mispronouncing that name uh they have a
1500 foot setback requirement
um which also includes not only
residential but schools
San Diego County has 1 000 foot setback
requirements and they also have a 300
foot setback for schools Child Care
Centers hospitals religious facilities
fire stations
or Sheriff's Station
Malibu has 500 Malibu California has 500
foot setbacks from schools playgrounds
and parks and a presumptive ban on
residential areas now again all of these
need to have their waiver process
but they can require a high burden to
prove
and a local jurisdiction can do this for
many reasons completely independent of
Health concern
they can say we don't like these
unsightly things in residential areas no
matter how much we dress them up with
whatever it looks like some kind of tree
that's in our area uh we put them in
church looking buildings we make it look
like a steeple uh they're still just
ugly
people don't like them nearby they
reduce property values perhaps
this is a non-health reason it is
perfectly permissive
another good reason to very much
regulate where these devices might be
particularly in residential areas
is if you put one near a corner say
where there is a cul-de-sac a street
that only has one means of entrance
these things are as Susan Foster going
to tell you a little bit sometimes they
are fire hazards
you need to as a local jurisdiction make
sure that if one of these works you take
fire
well everybody would have a means to
escape and go somewhere else around it
in that regard one other area where
local jurisdictions are beginning to
implement more regulation and I would
encourage you to put this in any
legislation that you have
emphasize that the local jurisdiction
can still make sure that these
facilities
of when constructed will be compliant
with all fire electrical and other
structural Safety Code
whether they be national state or local
there are codes that require that things
these things be designed properly
if they require the registered
professional engineer present a design
that shows and says up front I have
looked at this it will be wired properly
it meets all electrical codes and it
meets also applicable structural safety
requirements
um local jurisdictions can we do this
they're they're increasingly do this
because as you are about to find out
many of these facilities for some reason
seem to take fire
I'll be happy to answer any questions
thank you Mr McCullough very interesting
uh I will do a Chairman's privilege and
ask a question first just curious based
on the examples that you were giving
other than safety if there was any uh
legislation there was to come forward
involving say uh or pertaining to the
examples that you gave would you say
that that legislation would be more
appropriate for uh Science and Tech
committee or more appropriate for
now
um your legislature handles its
committee assignments
but I
um you know there are many ways to deal
with that maybe both committees should
weigh in on it but this does seem to be
a Science and Tech issue
um although of course
any legislation would have to take into
account
um the way that the state has delegated
to your local municipalities how they
exercise their zoning
so
um you know maybe a joint call maybe a
joint reference
um
you do have to make sure when you write
any legislation about zoning that you
kind of make sure that it works with
whatever the existing law is because as
municipalities are considering these
Wireless ordinances what they typically
do is they put it into their code their
local code and they have to make it work
within the existing code even though
they are making amendments they will use
similar definitions they will use
similar processes as they do for any
other kind of land use permit
thank you any other question
represent Kelly Pitts
they're gonna be glad to get rid of me
um you seem to be talking about new
construction
what about add-ons when they're adding
on
this particular service to an existing
Tower
um how do you regulate that because the
Talent is already there and they're just
there are two kinds of
additions to an existing facility
one is called co-location
where
um you may have say an existing Tower
with
only one wireless provider having
equipment there and a second wireless
provider is going to come in put more
equipment and put more antennas on the
tower
that's called co-location
um the FCC has established a shot clock
period for that I believe it's 90 days
um but otherwise uh the municipality is
still free to ensure for example that it
is code compliant
they can make sure that the tower uh
hopefully is already aesthetically
pleasing
I you do find that without a country
most local jurisdictions actually
encourage co-location
they want people to put their facilities
any new facilities where there is
already a tower and this is especially
so when it comes to macro Tower
so oh you know I think actually what you
might want to do is encourage local
jurisdictions to uh put when they are
prioritizing where they want new
facilities to prioritize co-location up
top because as you know it is already
there
there was a second kind that I do need
to mention
um it's what they call an exempt
facility you may have an existing Tower
and an existing wireless equipment and
the wireless provider that is already
there
wants to swap out some of the gear or
maybe put some new antennas on there
well that is a special kind of
application for which there is a
particular Federal piece of legislation
and some FCC rules
they're basically must approve in other
words if they meet the criteria for it
being an exempt facility
then the local jurisdiction does not
have much Choice
um so long as
you know it still meets safety
requirements for example
that's probably for the most part a must
approve but once again this is going in
you would you would probably prefer that
they put equipment where there's already
facilities and towers and having new
Talent
thank you
okay
um see no question from our committee
I'll take questions from other members
uh representative barinsky
uh thank you for taking my question
um on the examples uh there's quite a
wide range of distances for Shelburne
M.A uh it's 3 000 feet for schools and
then in New York there's a 500 feet
um so with such a wide range which is
the correct distance to place these
towers thank you
if you were talking about setbacks I'm
going to support the um
the committee's recommendation of 1600
feet uh that's an appropriate distance
um even small cells can work at that
distance remember again and this is a
presumptive setback
um it is the way that we want them to
design and try to configure their
Networks
if the wireless provider can show that
it needs a shorter distance then there
probably does need to be a waiver
process for it to come in Meet the
appropriate burden approved and show
that um you know a shorter separation
distance
uh is necessary or else it is an
okay uh last question and I think you
answer this uh in your uh discussion but
I'll ask it again
if a community is going to put in a
setback
they must provide a reason for that
setback uh other than health
reasons or emission reasons
um did I understand that correctly is is
that they they need to prove why they
well if we are talking about an
ordinance
um or a
piece of State legislation that is
telling a local jurisdiction what it
should put in an ordinance then yes I
would recommend that there be in the
findings whether it be of the
legislation or the local ordinance the
reason why
they are preferring to have these
setbacks fall zones and separation
distance on a presumptive basis and
there are many reasons that are fully
lawful under under the federal act uh
including Aesthetics including property
values
um including other visual effects and
then of course electrical firing
structural safety
if they invoke these reasons and then I
think that it is perfectly permissible
and of course with the waiver process
you will not have a problem with
thank you
see no further questions thank you very
much for your testimony Mitch McCullough
I appreciate it very much and I
appreciate you keeping it short that was
great thank you I'm going to call on I
think I'm going to go uh deviate over
here and call on a is there a Gerald
brushberg is it
here yes he's here physically uh you're
invited to come up and come to the mic
thank you chair and committee members
uh
thank you chair and committee members I
appreciate the opportunity to provide
some additional uh information I'm a
clinical professor of radiology and
radiation oncology at the University of
California uh at Davis and uh my
credentials and experience in this area
have been provided to you in a handout
on the very last page you'll find uh
more detail regarding my experience
excuse me if you could get a little
closer to the mic please so we can all
um in the packet that I've given you I
don't want to go over every single point
of information here but I wanted to
point out
um several that I think will be helpful
uh to provide some additional details of
what you've heard uh already
so uh if we could first turn uh
um well oh and by the way I failed to
mention that there is a disclaimer
on page two item four of course I
represent myself and my viewers don't
necessarily represent the views of my
University or or other institutions that
I have been Affiliated or I'm currently
affiliated with
okay having said that uh we could turn
to
area of you know the expert opinions and
it's been said that
that the FDA uh doesn't have
uh regulatory Authority in this area
that's true but it doesn't mean that
they have not reviewed the science or
opined on its
safety of Wireless technology
in their latest fact
um statement they say as you can see on
slides 19 and 20 that to date no
consistent or credible scientific
evidence of health problems is caused by
exposure to radio frequency energy
emitted by cell phones and then they go
on in the next slide to explain
um that the gold standard for assessment
of risk to the public are largely
epidemiological studies
and I say that the currently available
epidemiological studies Public Health
surveillance data and supportive
laboratory studies on cell phone
radiation provide abundant evidence to
support the fda's determinations that's
a direct quote not my interpretation but
their opinion
the next uh slide 21 which is very
difficult to read but I can provide you
with a more visible copy later if you
wish but it basically represents a whole
number of uh committees have been put
together by
countries and agencies around the world
that have asked the same question you
know as it say for the public to be
exposed to RF energy at the levels at or
below the standard
and I think when you review these
documents if you so wish you'd find that
there there is a consensus that doesn't
mean that there aren't questions and it
doesn't mean that we know everything
that we'd like to know or everything
that uh can be known but based on the
evidence as it existed at the time that
these various panels review the science
and some of these are very very recent
the vast majority of them in fact all on
this list that I could find aren't
supportive health and safety standards
that are very similar to the ones in
if you want to turn to slide 25s on page
13.
this is a report by IRC which issues the
support periodically it's referred to as
the world cancer report
um and it details cancer research and
recommendations for cancer prevention
they did review both ionizing and
non-ionizing radiation as you can see
and when they got to the study of RF and
this is a very recent report
first of all
RF radiation is not listed by IRC in the
world cancer report as a carcinogen
[Music]
it's true that it was listed in an IR
committee report as a possible
carcinogen but this is a more recent and
up-to-date statement from iarc which
says that most of the epidemiological
evidence does not support an association
between mobile phone use and tumor
occurrences in the head which is part of
the body with the highest exposure
levels the radio frequency
electromagnetic fields and studies
reporting positive associations
it is difficult to exclude various forms
of bias such as recall bias and
if we can turn to page 20 or to slide 27
again the National Cancer Institute is
does not
have a regulatory Authority in this area
but they they care about what does and
and likely does not cause cancer and
they have had several fact sheets
one in particular that I think is very
clear is
um they were they've said about the
cancer-causing effects of RF energy at
slide 27 and it says although there have
been some concerns that radio frequency
energy from cell phones how close the
head may affect the brain and other
tissues today there's no evidence from
studies in cells animals or humans that
RF radio frequency energy can cause
cancer
uh there was a concern if you look at
next slide 28
um
about long-term effects and children
fortunately one of the largest or the
largest study was recently published in
February of this year it's referred to
as the Moby kids study
and it involved over 2 000
individuals in
a number of different countries I think
it was 15 or so and the conclusion which
I'll just direct your attention to at
the bottom right is that they found no
increase of neuroepithelial brain tumors
either in relationship to wireless phone
I know that uh there's been testimony
about the ntp study and a lot of uh
concern about what the study said and
what it didn't say
ntp itself has
tried to provide some color around that
issue and if you look at slide 29
they have an FAQ this is from the ntp
themselves
and they asked the question that is
often asked of them
which is how do RF levels used in the
studies compare to typical human
exposures
and they make the point that the
exposures in the experiments were much
much higher
than would be expected
from use of cell phones or even or in
particular cell towers in an environment
um
and then they ask do the rat and mouse
studies apply to humans and their answer
is
the findings in animals cannot be
directly applied to humans for two key
reasons
first exposure levels and the durations
were greater than what people receive
and the second bullet is that rats and
mice received rfr across their whole
bodies which is different than the more
localized exposures people get from cell
phones
now to put it more in perspective I
think you would need to compare the
levels of exposure that they use to what
is allowed by the FCC for whole body
exposure
and there the
um you can see that on the very last
line of this slide that the exposures
range from somewhere between 18 to 75
times greater than the maximum that is
allowed for public exposure so that is
to their point about it not being
the next point I wanted to make is about
uh the amount of conflicting data and
I'm sure it's been very frustrating for
you to receive what seems like absolute
fact on one side an absolute fact on the
other side and and the reality is is
that it's uh it's not quite so clear
and research in and of itself uh is not
a precise science like physics for
example it involves biological studies
which have large margins for potential
air
and an epidemiological studies which was
the study of disease of populations and
there are any number of potential
problems that can occur in such a study
my professor of epidemiology said to me
uh I think it was the first state of the
class that the best thing about
epidemiology is that it studies the
organism of interest you know us
and then she said but then it's downhill
in a hurry and what she meant and what
we spent the rest of the time in our
class talking about
were all the kinds of biases that can
creep into these studies and you see
some of them there on this list recall
in bias
effects of uh inaccurate reporting
exposure assessment limitations and
sufficient follow-up inadequate
statistical power and so forth
um and then on the next slide I want to
make the point that's been made many
times by other scientists and especially
Journal editors is that our current
scientific literature is really quite
mixed with regard to the quality of the
science
these are statements from nature
and from Journal science and from Forbes
basically saying that
maybe half of the studies are are cannot
be replicated
and Richard Horton who's the editor to
Chief at the time of the Lancet was
quoted in the limited time saying that
the case against science is
straightforward much of the literature
perhaps half May Simply Be untrue
so if you turn to slide 33
it really is the quality of the science
that is the center of the controversy at
least in my view
and what you have if you start at the
top there
is a slide 33. uh you have an assertion
of a non-thermal adverse Health effect
of course that is a a very important and
Sensational item and so the media covers
it with a great zest and it no doubt
increases public anxiety
however the resolution of such a claim
requires verification replication other
studies which can take years to do
if they fail to confirm the original
study which is often the case
that receives very little or no media
attention
and so you have this perpetuation of
many false claims that erodes public
just to give you one example
um
this is a paper that was published in a
peer-reviewed journal
um as well thought of
it was a paper by Dr uh
Martin Paul who has been cited
previously in this committee as a as one
of the champions of explaining the
mechanism by which RF energy
can adversely affect human health at
non-thermal levels
and he goes on to explain in his theory
that um
that is specifically regarding the 5G
millimeter waves
that the electric fields are almost
completely absorbed up the outer one
millimeter of the body due to their High
dielectric constant
of biological aqueous phases however the
magnetic fields are highly penetrating
well this if you turn to slide 37
is a fundamental error of basic physics
that most high school physics teachers
if not their students would be aware
uh electromagnetic radiation is a
Quantum phenomena it
it is one of the part of the standard
model of elementary particle physics
it's referred to as a photon of energy
and Elementary means that it cannot be
subdivided any further into its
component parts
uh
insofar as his rationale and the
development of his conclusions are based
on this really fundamental error that
that the magnetic fields would continue
to penetrate while the electrical Fields
would not means that the all the
conclusion is drawn there would be
incorrect also start interrupt we are
running Along on time are you almost
within a minute of wrapping up because I
didn't think we were going to go through
all these slides here okay and we've
heard a lot of this technical stuff
before but if you can just wrap it up in
the next minute okay well let me just
turn to one thing that I think is maybe
more germane to and pertinent to the to
the issues before you and if you look at
um
it shows uh levels of RF exposure that
have been set by different countries and
organizations
and you can see that that some or are a
hundred times less than what is
recommended by the FCC or by the
European or who ignur recommendations
and uh and you say well okay there's a
lot of variability here why is that and
if I had time I would explain some of
that but I think the more important
point is that when you look at the
typical exposures from these types of
facilities and there was a very
extensive review
of individuals carrying monitors to
measure their exposure as a two almost a
quarter million people
in 13 different countries across Europe
North America Asia and Australia you can
see that the average maximums of
exposures were below even the most
restrictive of the standards that are
recommended by some organizations or
countries that believe that the
non-thermal is what needs to be
protected
and um
I'll just make one other point and I'll
close and that is that a vast majority
of individuals exposures that have cell
phones uh come from their cell phone
themselves maybe the Sprint has been
made before but the point I didn't hear
being made was that the amount of RF
energy that you or person staying next
to you gets from a wireless phone is
highly dependent on how strong the
signal is from the nearest base station
and that can range from its maximum
output to more than a thousand times
less than that and when it's at its uh
farthest output it's when you have a
weak signal like one bar
but when you have good coverage and you
have a strong signal the phone reduces
its power uh to a specific level that
can be a thousand times less than the
maximum that it's capable of under the
regulatory guidelines that are produced
by the FCC and so the bottom line is is
that if you want to reduce the vast
majority of public exposure from RF the
place to do it would be by having good
coverage low output from phones and and
that would have the largest potential
impact thank you
thank you Mitch Berg Mr bushberg sorry
uh seeing no other questions thank you
very much for your testimony I
appreciate it I think we're going to do
a slight deviation here because I would
like to have a I I know that
luiki thank you
uh would would like to speak on a
different idea and I'd like to save him
for last if you will so we can
wrap it up there I'd like to call on
uh
Susan Foster if she uh we okay CeCe
would you like to speak next please go
ahead
next go ahead
microphone please
you're here and and please speak clearly
and closely thank you um I don't mean to
disrupt the meeting I'm just um I'm
electromagnetic sensitive and so it's
really difficult for me to be in this
room right now
um my name is Jen white I live in the
Monadnock region of New Hampshire I gave
you my testimony I'm going to divert a
little bit and just speak from the heart
um so I um developed developed
electromagnetic sensitivity about 12
years ago
um I've been a small business owner for
about 20 years and through continued use
of Wireless technology I aim cell phone
up to my head for you know basically 10
years every single day
um Wi-Fi in my home a smart meter on my
home and also a rad tower that was
behind our house at the time we lived in
Connecticut so behind our house on the
Yukon research facility property so in
close proximity to our home so basically
with all of that exposure I developed a
Sensitivity I didn't ask for this it
happened to me the gentleman that just
spoke earlier talked about you know
you're seeing two so you're hearing two
sides what's the reality I'm the reality
this is what happens when people are
exposed over the long term to Electro to
RF radiation
um you know I've always been very
healthy I'm 47 years old now I developed
this when I was 35. I had always eaten
organic
exercised did everything right and
um you know I I developed this because I
was not given the opportunity to know
the evidence of what was happening to me
I found out the hard way
and so I'm here to plead with you to
consider HB 1644 on some level I know
that maybe you can't have the registry I
know that maybe you need to call in
another committee to be here but for the
sake of people like myself who you know
really would love to be able to live a
normal life but now I'm unfortunately
not able to because this happened to me
and I don't want this to happen anybody
else this has literally changed my life
and not for the good
um my husband and I recently went to our
15-year wedding anniversary we went to
an Airbnb in The Lakes region of New
Hampshire we checked into our Airbnb to
find out that it's a 5G Wi-Fi home
within an hour my body was literally
shaking because I couldn't be in that
environment
thankfully we were able to unplug
everything and I was able to coexist and
enjoy my anniversary but these are
things that people like me cannot be
around and I'm just one of many but I'm
here to ask you to release and really
consider this because
I feel like you know I'm one that's
speaking up right now but this is
affecting so many people and it's only a
matter of time that this is going to
affect everybody in this room
so I'm just asking you to really really
consider this it would mean so much to
people like myself as I mentioned you
know this has affected my life I'm 47
and I'm not able to be in this room
right now without my body shaking
so thank you
thank you very much and we appreciate
your concern and we do recognize that
people are having issues uh for whatever
reasons are out there no doubt about
that we have any questions from the
community
uh seeing none uh you're that thank you
so much for your testimony thank you
I'm going to call on a second from last
year uh Miss Susan Foster if she's on
line I believe
Michael I'm here uh can you hear me
I uh we can hear you notice clearly as
the others and we don't see a picture
yet either
no there's no picture I
I woke up without a voice so I'm hoping
you can hear me okay go ahead
provider and an honorary firefighter
with the San Diego Fire Department
I would like to share a cautionary tale
review about firefighters of California
and ask you to do everything in your
power
all residents of New Hampshire with the
most significant setbacks each City
entire legally a
fire stations have long been a desired
and early Target I'm sorry to interrupt
you I'm sorry you're you're coming in a
little bit broken up is um is there
something you can do maybe closer to the
mic or or something
I thought
I could give me a number I can call in
but this is
it it is not a good connection can we uh
yeah yeah the whole Community is having
a hard time understanding uh like every
other word
is there anything is there something
you could try that
yes I'm just gonna try to put you on
speaker and up with our microphone to
see if that helps them hear you a little
bit better so just one second
oh
okay if you could turn off the mic to
your computer just mute yourself and
then use your landline let's see how
okay hopefully you all can hear me
is that a go Jennifer are you guys able
this gives you a little amplification at
your Center
could you just um do a test again Susan
okay all right good morning my name is
yeah it's clear
um
okay Jennifer I couldn't hear Pat
all right good morning my name is Susan
Foster I am a medical writer and an
honorary firefighter with the San Diego
Fire Department
I would like to share a cautionary tale
with you about the firefighters of
California
and ask you to do everything in your
power to protect all residents of New
Hampshire with the most significant
setbacks each City and town can legally
obtain
fire stations have long been desired and
an early Target of the of the
Telecommunications industry
industry favors fire stations as
locations because they are almost always
placed near population centers and
heavily traveled roadways
the Telecom industry wants to reach
people in their homes and on the road
Telecom has not had difficulty talking
municipalities into granting leases on
fire stations because the cities in town
to reap the revenue from these lead thus
firefighters who often work and sleep at
these stations have a substantial 24 7
exposure to cell towers that the
industry consistently promises our low
energy and one one thousandth of the
radiation the FCC allows
such reassurances rainfalls on
firefighters experience clusters of
neurological and immunological illnesses
after years of spending shift after
shift in stations that are also home to
the Telecom industry's Towers
stance firefighters have taken in
California to keep 5G off their stations
should give every American family
heightened concern about the cell towers
that are creeping into their cities
schools and neighborhoods often without
local control without notification and
without environmental review
the firefighters of California have have
spent 15 years and millions of dollars
fighting cell towers on their stations
let me explain how this started
in 2004 I organized a specked brain scan
pilot study of firefighters who have
been exposed to a cell tower on their
station for over five years we found
brain abnormalities in all firefighters
tested as a result of these findings I
co-authored resolution 15 which passed
overwhelmingly by the International
Association of firefighters resolution
urged more resolution 15
urged a moratorium on the placement of
cell towers on fire stations in the U.S
and Canada
that was trumped by the
Telecommunications Act but the spirit of
the
resolution did educate
in 2015 I helped the Los Angeles iaff
locals as they aligned with law
enforcement Union to fight first net
Towers on their stations I have assisted
with a cancer cluster in a fire station
in California with a wireless hub next
door to their station in a station on
the East Coast with a cell tower
operating adjacent to the station I will
add that these were cancer clusters and
relatively young men with
non-presumptive Cancers meaning these
were not cancers typically related to
the profession of firefighting
let me tell you a little bit about why
the spec brain scan study came about
a group of 25 firefighters manned two
each with a single cell tower
the first Towers in town in the late
1990s there were three rotating shifts
every man worked for 24 hours every
other day
in one station Telecom had placed their
Tower directly in front of the station
it was beamed directly across the living
quarters of the firefighters to reach 12
Lanes of traffic on the other side
the men
had been experiencing a range of
neurological symptoms since the towers
in front of their stations have been
activated five years earlier
all but two of the men experienced
neurological symptoms while working in
these two stations there's 23 out of 25
men
the symptoms the men experienced were
identical to what we described as the
constellation of neurological symptoms
known as Electro sensitivity or EHS or
more technically electromagnetic
sensitivities EMS declared by the U.S
access board in 2002 to be a disability
EHS or EMS is not in itself a disease
but it is rather a term used to describe
multiple neurological and immunological
conditions which are a result of the
body's inability to tolerate radio
frequency electromagnetic radiation
the symptoms experienced by the
firefighters who participated in the
specked brain scan study were similar to
firefighters in other stations who live
in the shadow of cell count
yeah specific to the men we studied it
is important to note that all the men
had passed rigorous physical and
cognitive exams prior to being hired by
the fire department
their symptoms included headaches
extreme fatigue cognitive impairment
anesthesia-like sleep where the men woke
up
for 9-1-1 calls as if they had been
drugged
inability to sleep depression anxiety
unexplained anger and immune suppression
manifest in frequent colds and flu-like
symptoms
real life examples of these symptoms are
best briefly characterized by first the
firefighters got lost on 9-1-1 calls and
the town they had grown up in on several
occasions in one instance four
firefighters died in the rig in a stupor
with the alarm sounding in the
background unable to remember how to
start the engine
medic with 20 years of experience who
had never made a mistake forgot basic
CPR in the midst of resubstituting a
coronary victim
the brain scans of these six men
revealed a pervasive hyper excitability
of the neurons in certain parts of the
brain these findings suggest the
exposure to RF or micro microwave
radiation was causing the neurons to
continually fire in these areas without
benefit of rest
when brain cells cannot rest they
ultimately die
the scans further revealed that other
sections of the brain that should have
been functional showed hypoperfusion or
decreased blood flow suggesting
impairment in these particular areas
foreign
you have heard and you are going to
continue to hear from industry
Representatives repeatedly that
non-thermal levels of RF radiation from
cell towers do not cause harm as they
are below the regulatory guidelines
offered by the FCC
if you can remember one thing that I
tell you this morning I want you to
remember that the tower in front of the
station causing the greatest harm to the
firefighters measured at 1 1000 of what
the FCC allows one one thousand
the firefighter's most important lesson
to US state legislators and as a nation
may be that if we allow a build out of
cell tower such that they are common in
place in front of homes and schools as
they know are on fire stations we may be
facing a tsunami of neurological
symptoms
forms of neurological damage I worry
about the most are cognitive impairment
and learning disabilities for children
and for adults early onset dementia and
Alzheimer's disease
the rate of people dying from
Alzheimer's disease in the U.S Rose by
55 over a 15-year period according to uh
new relatively new information from the
CDC the direct and indirect costs to the
state for Alzheimer's and a host of
related neurological and immunological
diseases could be catastrophic for New
Hampshire and the country as a whole
clearly the state of California honored
the sacrifice of its firefighters and
its concern about the help that they
face from cell towers having granted an
exemption to them in ab57 SB 649 and
ab-57 which passed recently was signed
into law by Governor Newsom on October
4th 2021.
these exemptions allow the firefighters
to fight the towers without the onerous
burden of the shot clock and make it
very difficult for telecoms to place 5G
on their station
yet think about this exemptions for
firefighters the strongest of the strong
Among Us on some residential areas have
zero setbacks from residential
if the government of California
acknowledges that firefighters cannot do
their jobs quickly and efficiently such
that the safety of the people and
property of firefighters protect may be
compromised what have the legislators
been told that the rest of society is
not privy to
firefighters have fought to keep cell
towers off their stations because they
know they are among the strongest of the
strong when it comes to the
professionals among us yet they have
suffered harm living and working in the
presence of cell towers and the
firefighters know they cannot carry out
their duties to protect the general
public as they should if they are indeed
impaired further they know that
that people they protect the general
public are almost certainly more
vulnerable than they are logic tells us
that the firefighters the strongest of
the strong are harmed and the weakest
and most vulnerable Among Us are at even
greater risk
now I will quickly address buyers I have
worked with Scott McCullough in
California for two years exploring
causes of these horrific fires we have
found in Southern California alone four
major wildfires in the last 15 years
have started in whole or in part by
telecommunications equipment
these Telecom start initiated fires have
caused multiple lives and over six
billion dollars in Damages
I will add one final comment
in the late 1990s Dr bushberg from whom
you just heard approved the cell tower
at the fire station where we found brain
damage and every firefighter we tested
he assured the Town Council of the
safety of the towers that caused brain
damage as proven unspect brain scans
and even though cancer is not my area of
expertise I will add that the world
can't report that Dr bushberg reference
is not a systematic review of the cancer
sign thank you very much
uh thank you very much for your
testimony do we
does the committee have any questions uh
before I go down we're we're trying to
ascertain right now there is a question
as to whether or not because uh he also
sits on the Science and Tech committee
uh representative uh brisney would be on
our subcommittee we're trying to
ascertain that right now so
um apparently there's a terminology term
that we're exploring right now so uh
shouldn't make that much of a difference
in terms of overall work but we want to
make sure that that we get a correct
um so with that being said any questions
thank you so much for your testimony
very good information there uh we're
going to move on uh we have limited time
left so I'm going to call on
representative lewicki who would like to
speak on an idea that uh that he'd like
to present and then after that
presentation the committee will go into
a brief discussion on what we're going
to do don't forget CC wanted maybe give
CeCe
she's already spoken oh not in this
meeting
oh I'm sorry see I'm Excuse me I I got
those names confused in that case would
briefly please
thank you so much my name is CeCe or
Cecilia Doucette I'm the director of
Massachusetts for safe technology and as
Susan Foster just indicated the
gentleman who was here speaking
presumably on behalf of himself I just
checked with him he is a paid expert
from ctia the wireless industry
Courtney gilardi asked that I read you a
brief paragraph she is the mother who
was here speaking with her daughter from
Pittsfield Massachusetts where a cell
tower was placed by Verizon on top of
their neighborhood and she indicates
Courtney gilardi and her 14 year old
daughter Amelia could not be here today
although they testified last time as the
human evidence of Wireless harm as part
of an 18-month investigation into 17
plus people getting sick from a 4G LTE
macro Tower in a residential
neighborhood the Pittsfield Board of
Health met with paid Verizon consultant
Professor Swanson and I will read to you
in a moment there
investigation of Dr Swanson the Board of
Health also met with the doctors who
treated their injuries due to
non-ionizing radiation from the cell
tower the board unanimously concluded
the cell tower must cease and desist
operations immediately as their homes
had been made uninhabitable due to the
cell tower Miss gilardi reports
neighbors still are sleeping in cars
trailers and on mattresses on the floor
of temporary accommodations just to
escape the Relentless nausea headaches
dizziness insomnia tinnitus and other
symptoms medically diagnosed and caused
by the tower the gelardes Are Not Alone
they are asking you for setbacks to
protect and prevent harm so that no one
in New Hampshire has to suffer by losing
their health and their homes the way
they did
I would like to read to you from the
Pittsfield Board of Health investigation
into the cell tower and from the
emergency order that they issued to
Verizon
item 21 on page 10 this board has
reviewed Professor Swanson's
presentation and discussion because he
spoke to their board as well and finds
Professor Swanson's conclusions several
of which are strident and absolute to
lack credibility a major problem with
Professor Swanson is that he speaks as a
purported expert about matters of human
health and disease and medical and
scientific studies about the health
effects of exposure to wireless
radiation but he lacks any academic or
professional qualifications in this
field
Professor Swanson is a professor of
theoretical physics Professor Swanson's
research interests focus on esoteric
topics in nuclear physics cosmology
hadronic physics especially in learning
how quarks and gluons build the universe
all 124 Professor Swanson's published
scientific studies are limited to these
subject areas Professor Swanson is not a
medical doctor Professor Swanson has no
professional training or qualifications
in medicine medical research biology
Environmental Studies Public Health
epidemiology or toxicology and his
professional credentials show no such
expertise
yet Professor Swanson rejects more than
2 000 peer-reviewed scientific studies
showing that wireless radiation May or
does negatively impact human health as
outliers by Fringe scientists who may be
conspiracy theorists with an ax to grind
and assert that their studies all show
confirmation bias Professor Swanson
asserts unequivocally that the
scientific consensus is that wireless
radiation cannot cause human harm
the board finds that Professor Swanson
lacks the qualifications and expertise
to make such sweeping statements and his
credibility as a witness is severely
undermined hereby in item 23 on page 11
they continue the Verizon Wireless also
submitted to this board documents which
consist primarily of self-promotional
brochures and industry-funded advocacy
pieces rather than peer-reviewed
scientific literature so thank you to
the Pittsfield Board of Health for
clarifying that the industry brings
forward supposed experts who are not
qualified to weigh in on this issue I
would like to thank the New Hampshire
commission that investigated the health
and environmental impacts of today's
Wireless technology
they composed a commission of Highly
qualified experts and they document the
peer-reviewed
non-industry-funded science in this
document that is in your hands today so
please go back to your own experts who
have done their due diligence but mostly
I want to speak about Solutions
I am honored to be a co-founder are you
into your last minute or so of uh yeah
summary what I want to do is give you an
assurance that there are so many
resources at your fingertip for
education I have helped to found a
non-profit out of Europe called Wireless
education where we have literally
off-the-shelf courses that could be
administered to schools and families in
about a half an hour online
for those who want to address the
municipal level Reinventing wires
teaches our towns the many reasons why
Wireless is no longer the preferred
choice for connectivity fiber to and
through the premises
and then for our schools we have a whole
tool kit with tech safe schools that we
can
um bring to you you don't have to do
this on there on your own even the U.S
collaborative for high performance
schools already has a module for new
construction and renovation on how to
make an EMF safe environment there are
green School certifying organization the
hartsburg School in Massachusetts has
already gone hardwired they put a switch
on the wall with a timer you only use
Wi-Fi for the minimum amount of time and
you use hardwired connections throughout
the building
and the amazing film generation Zapped
we have done screenings in stratum we
have done screenings in Keene we can get
out and educate at the community level
and again folks this is not rocket
science plug in your technology and turn
off the wireless antennas you will have
a much safer connection you will have a
screaming fast signal it won't drop like
Wireless signals do and hardwired
solutions consume 10 times less energy
than the wireless cloud and all of its
distribution centers so thank you very
much
thank you uh thank you for your
presentations again always a pleasure to
see you here uh I have a I I don't have
any questions as the committee oh by the
way I I want to clarify uh I guess as
the as the chair of the subcommittee uh
I I have the authority to appoint
representative bresney to be a member of
the subcommittee which is right but
that's because he is a member of the
Science and Tech committee I can do that
I cannot do that for members that are
not part of the Science and Tech
committee so that explanation was just
given to me any questions from our
subcommittee members at all
okay thank you very much oops yeah let
thank you for taking my question I'm
seeking an opinion from you
um I mean you're I think the foregone
conclusion that you would say is that
telecommunications uh paid Consultants
on the national level have an advantage
over municipalities advancing FCC
regulations in favor of the industry
yes so a follow-up on that would be
we are speaking right now about trying
to get municipalities involved both in
educational level and on the zoning
level to
um increase their voice in where these
Soul towers are placed uh
not
is that the most effective use of our
time and strategy in order to get
municipalities involved I think as
representative abrami mentioned at the
opening of this meeting if you are to
take courageous action two directions
would be very helpful to the general
public one let's get the education out
there because they've only been told by
industry that all Wi-Fi all the time is
the way to go and during the pandemic we
handed every student every child
a wireless device to go home and access
their education with not one shred of
training to just say run the ethernet
cable to the device go into the device
and turn off all the antennas now you
can safely access your education so we
desperately need the education to the
general public secondly if we do not
update our zoning bylaws town by town
then the industry is going to continue
to come in and promote the financial
Revenue they'll receive from putting
technology in at the curb that's
radiating your citizens so I think you
need to get the education out there and
I think you need to get zoning bylaws in
place that protect within the framework
of the existing FCC law because
otherwise as we're seeing they are
putting these cell towers 10 feet from
people's homes I was in Minneapolis
yesterday and I did a generation zap
screening there
and there is a woman who has multiple
sclerosis
the neighbors were all working from home
they see a truck pull up with a big long
pole on it 20 neighbors went outside and
said what are we doing and they said
we're installing a 5G small cell antenna
10 feet from This Woman's bedroom
the residents 20 of them came out
because they're all working from home
and said oh no we don't want this here
and so the installer called the police
the police came and said well actually
with First Amendment rights they have
every right to be out here peaceably
Gathering
so the police sent the guy away they've
come back now twice and every time the
neighbors get out there to very
peacefully protest
and every time a higher level of police
has come the sergeant the captain and
every time they have protected the
citizens rights to be there and they
have learned that if there are people or
cars there these installers cannot
install these because it's a high risk
if there are people there so let that be
a word of encouragement to anybody in
your community if you see these coming
in because they are in and they are
coming Fast and Furious before the
industry is made to stop we believe and
as attorney Scott McAuliffe believes you
have the power to provide your
municipalities with information on how
legally today they can start updating
their zoning bylaws because if you don't
have it in your zoning code you're a
okay
thank you okay with that being said I'd
like to invite uh thank you very much
for your testimony I'd like to invite
representative Loki lewicky to give his
views on some alternative ideas
okay thank you Mr chairman
um I'm going to just give a little bit
of background
um I have spent most of my life working
as an electrical engineer I first became
acquainted with a spectrum analyzer
around 55 years ago and I have heard a
lot of talk about
um
the
wireless being just a monolithic thing
and one of the things I say is the dose
makes the poison just for comparative
purposes I counted up and we have
approximately this is the actual
electromagnetic radiation in this room
right now we have approximately 60
fluorescent bulbs if they're 100 watts
each that's 6000 watts of power coming
from them most of it is visible light
some of it is uh infrared we have two
white things over there on the wall
we've climbed up got the numbers on them
these are wireless
transceivers and they are from memory 12
watts each which is one 250th of the
total power in this room
I also make a habit of visiting um
tower sites and so forth and look at the
name plates on the emergency generators
and a large cell phone tower will have a
50 to 100
um
kilowatt generator attached so what
you've got here is we've got 25 watts
6000 watts and on a big cell phone
installation 50 000 to 100 000 Watts and
so we've got artists of magnitude
difference and once again the dose makes
the poison and the other thing is don't
be stupid I heard an anecdote of someone
where they had a kid in the dorm room
and they had one of these things right
at close to the head of the bed you know
don't be stupid it's you don't need to
uh get any more exposure than necessary
but given that dosage differences the
power differences it makes sense to me
to have standards based upon power and
possibly on frequencies used which I
have heard no information whatsoever on
we've heard a lot of talk from
authorities and everybody's got their
own set of authorities and the argument
from Authority is a logical fallacy
which means it's not something that's
very convincing
what I would suggest is that we
differentiate between the big cell phone
towers and smaller ones if we have a de
minimum standard which might be man this
is pulling numbers out of the Hat it's
not anything uh definitive but if we say
100 watts and 100 feet of separation
from a normally inhabited building
is would be one standard and then for
the big towers we could have a much
greater standard and it's not going to
satisfy whatever we do will not satisfy
everyone but if we do have that dual
standard and I don't think we'd ought to
try to have Define the standards in
watts per square centimeter or something
like that because that just opened the
door to a whole lot of uh you know
concern and discussion and uh haggling
but if for instance if we put in the
zoning regulations or if we put it in
Statewide you know 100 Watts 100 feet
anything beyond that a longer larger
standard and once again I have still not
been convinced by any of the testifiers
that this is the right thing or the
wrong thing to do but I think it is
something we might be able to legislate
and might be something that we can
reasonably compromise on until we have
additional data
that's all I have
I have a question for you what when we
gave up and this is when we gave up
control of the Telecommunications
industry as a state
because we no longer can go to the puc
how do we legislate that I believe it
has to be on a local level that has to
okay uh thank you
um as a techie I'm talking about the
technical issues
um the legal issues and how it might be
implemented are outside of my purview I
found it kind of interesting that we
spent the first 45 minutes listening to
lawyers and we've had very little talk
on the technical issues
um but if we set something perhaps it
would not even be in statute how we
address this whether it should be in
statute whether it should be by uh
recommendation and how it would be
implemented as outside of my purview I'm
just saying you know if we can agree on
a dual standard with a diminishment
level for things that can be scattered
around for
um at a particular shorter distance and
then
um you know have the standard for the
higher level power levels and this would
end up effectively being
um you know a watch per square meter
standard but with just two levels
allowed
represent broski
uh thank you for taking my question on
page 22 slide 44 this is the art review
RF safety and wireless uh communication
State of New Hampshire
there's a diagram here that shows as the
distance grows between the user and the
cell tower the RF output goes to its
maximum and as a distance reduces the RF
output is at its minimum so can you
speak to Inc to having these setbacks
are they counterproductive or or how
does that um how does it cancel out by
having a larger setback thank you that
seems counterintuitive to me everything
obeys to some extent the cube squared
law or you know the surface of a sphere
at a specific distance tells how much uh
um the area
slow down a bit how many watts per unit
of area we might have and uh it if the
power is not at the source then the
power cannot be radiated that just
doesn't make any sense
um and so we know that they have
directional antennas we know that the
power is not all radiated in a sphere
it's they obviously try to have the
radiated power go to where the users are
however I don't think that they can
repeal something as simple as the cube
I guess just to confirm so does this is
do you agree with this slide that the
farther the user is from the tower that
the more radiation there is thank you no
I disagree it in certain cases that
won't be so if for instance the um
the antenna is not radiating down below
you could conceivably be at the base of
the Tower and have very little radiation
but if um the antenna is broadcasting
you know one would expect to have it be
somewhat cylindrical for something that
is a broadcast antenna as one increases
the distance then the power will go down
um although you know conceding that the
power at the pace of the towel may be
okay uh
I have a question from an individual
strengthened because of the distance
from the tower so
um I'm not sure what that means but
there may be a separation between what's
animating from the tower itself
difference between the powers and
energies being involved
that there's the device that's receiving
it and emanating there's the device
that's sending it pen emanating and
these are two different factors and then
we're always talking about sort of one
set of person in our phone when you get
into a room of people who are all on
their cell phones and there's you know
seven different signals aiming into
everything every single person's phone
this is also a part of a cumulative
effect and so uh that would be something
to
consider I think when you're talking
about whether the signal would be weaker
the farther away or stronger the closer
up
um so you need to separate which signals
we're talking about and then the
cumulative output of all of these
that does make sense however we're here
today to talk about cell phone towers
um what the other effects may be are
outside of our purview and outside of my
knowledge
I'd like to I just say uh we uh we don't
want to start getting into into the
weeds here that was not the purpose of
of this meeting today
um the as I said at the beginning of the
meeting we were here to determine
whether or not we think there is or is
not
um uh
a way to uh to have further legislation
forthcoming or or not uh I will get to
representative partial for one last
comment before we I go to my summary
this is the very short one thank you so
much for your testimony makes various
good sense and it does get in the weeds
I agree but your name for the record
okay seeing no further provided
testimony uh I'm going to uh go into a
deliberation here with our subcommittee
members I will say that
We Have Heard
both sides
uh over the course of several well over
a year two years
um and I would like to hear from my
subcommittee members what their thoughts
are on whether or not for whatever
reason if there should be some for some
type of legislation moving forward
however general or where it's directed
may be we're not here to solve the
problem right now we're here to
determine you know we either let the
subject die by saying there's no further
legislation required or we say that
there is some basis for further uh
legislation we're not quite sure what it
might be but it might cover this area so
I like to hear some thoughts from my
subcommittee members
you're free to speak represent Kelly
Pitts would you like to go first
oh sure since
um
I think there is
a place for further legislation and I
think that for the legislation has to do
with education and that was something I
was going to work on and I think it's
still necessary
we need to
form a resolution maybe a concurrent
resolution
or a bill with a very strong suggestion
that information be disseminated to the
towns
we get the information we get all these
uh people coming and talking to us and
that's great but some of the small towns
don't have that and the counties don't
have that I think all the information
pro and con needs to be disseminated and
disseminated quickly I think this should
be a bill with priority
we can't mandate that it be done but we
can strongly suggest that it be done and
by done done with the companies who are
investing in this technology and I also
believe that the companies who are
investing in this technology
whether we like it or not it's going to
happen but we should know where it is
and be able to get that information if
we have to on a foia on a 91a we need to
know where these towers are going up
where these attachments are going up
and
that's the only way we can judge if it's
making a difference in what we are doing
or seeing so I I believe that that kind
of legislation needs to come forth thank
you
just yeah just uh your friend my final
thought yes I mean I agree with the
education part
uh the other thing is that to come up
with a model model ordinance for our
towns to consider
that would cut mustard mustard with with
the FCC would not violate the federal
law
is something I'm willing to put forward
to help our communities
to you know like that last story we
heard about the whole you know the whole
street came out to protect one woman
there's something you know and I know
we've heard testimony both ways on the
science I mean we've heard it both ways
but
and look I'm not I'm not an extremist
you know you guys know me
I but I just I keep on coming back to
the fact that I've heard for a year and
a half in the commission that we had a
lot of testimony a lot of testimony on
this stuff
and that's why I bought legislation
because there's clearly there's
something here and I'm not convinced
that the federal government is doing its
job either
and so I'm I'm saying let's let's
Empower at least Empower our communities
to have a line of defense if they choose
to have have one leave it up to the
communities to to make that but I think
the state can help by
uh kind of blessing
I uh an ordinance model that would would
uh again because every Community does
not have the resource to come up with a
good ordinance and uh that would
withstand
the the fcc's you know the 1996 uh
telecommunication Act
so I think that's something that we can
do
and I I certainly would be working on
that
and I would hope that this committee
would would support that and as far as
the comment earlier about should it be
should we get the municipal involved
with this precedent for that we had one
Casino Bill years ago when the casino
bills were still were financed and and
Ways and Means work together on on on
going through that bill
so there there is that's a matter of
talking to the speaker uh uh whoever
that may be uh as to uh how to handle
such a bill okay thank you
thank you uh again so what I'm hearing
from our committee is that there is um a
a desire to to make a recommendation
that some form of legislation can uh
should be done on the subject matter
um I think it should center around
what's representative Kelly Pitts said
on education uh uh we uh we we don't
necessarily have to recommend whether
it's a resolution or a bill we just have
to recommend that there is some form of
legislation required and we can make a
recommendation on
um the it the the the areas that we
would like to see it explored like
education perhaps
um and uh and to um and also the things
that would enable uh communities to
pursue their um I guess you know zoning
changes and and things like that is that
the general feeling from the committee
I I don't disagree oh sorry I don't
disagree
um I we're still in the situation where
you know
I think we really need to talk about the
technical issues and unfortunately we
haven't gotten the kind of information
I'd be interested in it was the
professor from UNH and I said let's get
a spectrum analyzer drive around and see
what we see and we don't have that
information we could be in a very hot
spot here we could be a hundred yards
away and be in a very cold spot and I
don't know
uh we can certainly add the technical
aspects to our recommendation as far as
the types of things that some further
study might include I had a conversation
yesterday with uh chairman Vose and he
was in agreement that we can put in uh
whatever uh areas of interest that
further legislation could cover doesn't
necessarily have to be specific it can
be General it can be wide encompassing
just something to give an idea of what
type of legislation we might be looking
at so so I would agree with that
the chair can I kind of just react to
that so I I would support that
Department in the commission when we we
talked about these things we did we
talked about everything
and in that the problem was that doing
the measurements around the state
would cost money
and and knowing our legislature
you know where's that money coming from
do we mandate that the industry do
measurements perhaps
uh obviously they're going to they would
resist that but you you would think you
would think that somebody does
measurements right
and and I would say no one does
measurements and uh so
you know I would support measurements
but the issue becomes and then what time
of day where what direction
does beam forming there's all this other
stuff that you got to worry about
uh so
you know it does get complicated from a
science standpoint
again understanding the purpose of this
subcommittee is to make a recommendation
on whether or not we there should be
some legislation whether or not there's
there's a mandate or whether or not
there is funds involved would be the
subject of whatever Bill someone might
present later on which would open up a
whole
new window of opportunity for
testimonies and discussions on that
representative
thank you I in my opinion I don't think
it's necessary for us to make any
recommendations because
um if you've been in the legislature
long enough you know that some bills
come back every year I can give an
example not to go off on a tangent too
far but when I was a freshman legislator
in 2011 I spent a long time trying to
find
when a certain pet was was banned and I
couldn't find anything but one thing I
did see over and over and over again was
every term there was a bill for hemp
representative Owen he put that bill in
every every term some some of you might
have been here long enough to remember
that and then and then there's other
other bills no matter what the subject
is you can almost guarantee that
somebody's going to put in a bill about
it so I don't see this being any
different I'm sure somebody will put in
a bill next term
for for 5G technology and antennas and
and all that so
it's not necessary for us to vote on
anything today
well I I
would need to vote on something today
because representative bows is having an
executive session on October the 6th and
uh the recommendations of this committee
today will be the subject of their of
the full of the full committee vote and
he has to get a report in before a time
period so that's where function today is
to make a vote on whether we are not to
go forward or not I would say my opinion
is that
whether we do or don't make a
recommendation here you're right there
will be other bills that will be
submitted I'm I'm positive of that
um but the recommendation of this
committee could add some Credence to
whether or not
um
not in support of those bills per se but
it would add Credence to the fact that
some legislation still needs to to go on
because we feel there is something
something out there we can't put a cause
on it but we feel that if if we say no
legislation is required here my opinion
is that it would seem that the committee
was saying there is no further
discussion required on this subject at
all I'm not quite sure I agree with that
whereas if we say there is legislation
required uh in general terms we're
acknowledging that something is out
there something may have to get done and
we're saying that we're we're opening
the doors to any other legislation that
might come forward that might help with
the situation that's what I feel this
recommendation would say
go ahead oh I was gonna say
all I was going to say is that I think
that it's imperative that we say that we
need further legislation and that we
needed this term not study we need some
some serious serious discussion and
information to be disseminated about
this subject
I was going to ask you
um I know I'm I'm lameed up but when is
the filing period is it
December
I think it's November um I don't know
the exact date November so but but but
yeah I am lamed up but I think we need
to do everything I'm a dead duck but I
think we need to uh
recommend that legislation be drafted
and this committee if they recommend
legislation that has always been the
subcommittee that some members of the
subcommittee would get together and draw
up legislation and whether you know I
know it's an election year and nobody
I'm gonna be honest because I can now
nobody wants to do this during an
election year because everybody's busy
but I think that it's very important to
get OLS and get some ideas down OLS and
get it done and it's usually the members
of the committee where legislation has
yep thank you
um I didn't really understand what
prevents a talent from setting the
setbacks for the towers I assume that
most towns can put into their zoning
setbacks for these towers and then for
schools I mean I understand most schools
can Institute the program that was
described earlier with having no Wi-Fi
or having a timer that turns off the
Wi-Fi certain periods of time
um and then for the education having the
the state create education materials
um I don't know if the state has the
resources to do that and there's already
a lot of information I think if a school
district was interested in these things
they can reach out to all these
different organizations and learn more
and make their own decision on how they
want to do things
thank you
again those are all valid points to
discuss if we were discussing an actual
bill I think the purpose of this
subcommittee is to just decide whether
we want to say we we recommend further
legislative action maybe along these
general terms
whether a bill comes out of it or not is
the material as far as what the purpose
of this committee is for I I've heard
from everybody here so far on on a
committee uh
represent Parson you want a final word
oh I maybe not final thank you so much
uh and uh
I think that
I've used pretty much everything's up
and said here right upon Al
um I'm not sure if towns can be actually
initiate a setback but I agree with you
this is a this is a conversations best
held if you're going to be Drafting and
I think we need to say yes for the
legislation especially in terms of
empowering our municipalities so they
can make these setbacks they're most
deeply affected and they have the fewest
tools to really uh for self-education
for a fair and personal information
and they have less access to FCC than
telling the communications industry my
concern is very much lies with the
process of how we arrived at this point
to begin with
and the voice of our communities really
need to be heard in this and I also
think we have a comprehensive study
that's already been done and I think we
have rather than waiting for somebody
else to come forward with a bill we have
the momentum uh we have invested the
time and I just think we would amplify
our efforts by going ahead now to draft
legislation
foreign
thank you
uh yes thank you Mr chairman
um what I'd like would the subcommittee
perhaps give some idea of whether they
would support a dual standard similar to
1644 but with a de minimis uh level for
all right
um that sounds very specific I'm looking
for something general okay but look let
me tell you what what my thoughts are my
thoughts are that we recommend to our to
our full committee next week
that that we have that there should be
further legislation and it should and it
should
cover areas such as education Technical
and I I would I would also argue that it
should cover areas of of municipality
something that might get the committee
on municipality involved because this
this might involve it could involve
a bill could involve an RSA that affects
what type of zoning laws communities
could or or can't do I don't know uh the
museum the municipality people might
know but my recommendation would be that
we make it in those general terms that
whatever goes forward we recommend that
it should cover education technical
municipality concerns where rsas
involving zonings whatever does that
kind of answer your question or a
concern
um yes
okay with that being said I would like
to call for
um emotion from the The Sound Community
that we that we recommend further
legislative action be done covering the
subjects of RF radiation uh involving
education
um acknowledging the issues
um involving uh more technical aspects
that could involve it could involve
frequency as well as the power and that
we suggest that a priority be placed on
any legislation that that might be
considered along these lines and that
also uh the municip the committee on
Municipal and whatever the other words
are
um
County government Municipal and County
government B be involved in in such
further legislation as well
all those oh uh no you can't vote on
that yet
do I ever second okay all those in favor
say goodbye for saying aye aye opposed
I'm going to oppose because I believe
that there's going to be other bills
anyway
so noted committee improves uh five to
one who recommended to the full
committee for next week which I'm sure
uh thank you very much I'll declare this
subcommittee work session closed
to further
to further information I'm sure we'll be